hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to what
can you say about Animaniacs it was by
far one of the greatest cartoon shows
that was ever made for kids the reason
for that was a lot of the jokes were
written just as much for adults as they
were for kids but maybe some of these
jokes got a little too adult there were
a lot of hidden and you endows in the
show that were so sneaky that even the
Hollywood censors didn't catch them when
we were children we missed most of them
but now that we're older we can respect
the kind of humor that many people would
consider a little too risque for a
children's show which is why today I'm
going to bring you the top 11 scenes
that made it past the Warner Brothers
century board why top 11 because I like
to go one step beyond so with that said
sit back and enjoy the top 11 nautious
Anna maniac moments
number eleven you expect us poor
innocent children to climb up dangerous
scaffolding and paid naked people all
over a church number two come on you
guys we're gonna play truth or dare
number nine I got the beans I got the
cut to the brain
number seven Yakko can you conjugate Oh
me I've never even kissed a girl number
six
no no it's easy I'll conjugate with you
you're not everybody number five let me
go to the board and show you now look
number four give me the bird we'd love
to really but the Fox censors won't
allow it
number three whoa what else you got in
there
number two I'm your biggest fan what do
you say to that
I'd say puberty was inordinately kind to
you and the number one nautious annemiek
moment is no no no fingerprints
our bold for Wow how did the sensors
ever let that five stop they're getting
away with on kids shows these days it
just shows you that if you're subtle
enough you can get away with anything
even a children's cartoon
tomorrow I'll play the xylophone with my
books
well I hope you enjoy that I remember
Yakko spelled backwards this okay I have
no idea what that meg I'm the Nostalgia
Critic saying a new review next week